first of all Craig before we start
properly I have to express my extreme
disappointment with you
because you guys released this Einstein
tile I went and made this great video we
did all this recording and traveled
around Scotland and we were just about
to release it and then you went and
found another one a better one
well I guess we should have held off
until you released the first video that
would have been nice just a few weeks a
few weeks buffer and then we could have
done a whole and I've done it all again
but we've had to do a bit of surgery on
our first video and then we're going to
make another one later
you should give me a heads up and I'll
know for next time I should have I
should have let you know can I first
before we start talking about all this
excitement around these tiles just to
find a little bit about you
um
who are you where like you know tell me
where you are and where you're from and
what kind of job you do like where where
do you fit into the great jigsaw puzzle
of uh tiling nice well uh my name is
Craig Kaplan I am an associate professor
in the school of computer science at the
University of Waterloo which is one of
the larger uh universities in Canada
particularly known for math computer
science engineering but of course
great programs in all sorts of fields
I I kind of got into tilings as a
graduate student which was a long time
ago now but I uh in in a computer
Graphics course that was being taught
there as a graduate student as a final
project we did a program to let you draw
escher-like Tilex edit the shapes of
tiles and it was a lot of fun and after
that the professor of the course said
you know this this could be research
this could be something to play around
with and I my initial reaction was like
come on that's not research right that's
just playing around that's just having
fun which
if that if you ever say that to yourself
you're on to something right so I got
sucked in at that point but really A lot
of my work was about applications of
tiling Theory uh and computer Graphics
in Art and Design so I kind of came into
tyler3 Theory through the back door
right I I was interested in applying
what was already very well known and of
course with the mathematical background
I mean it was only natural I got sucked
into the big open problems and they were
just something to to ruminate over for
many years I never expected I'd make
much of a contribution to any of those
open problems but I'm very lucky to find
myself here today
Penrose tiling that you can't that you
guys have kind of knocked off its
pedestal
were you were you already super familiar
with that was that was that like you
know was that the celebrity tiling to
you oh yeah yeah I mean the Penrose
tailing is absolutely and maybe still is
the celebrity the the A-list celebrity
in the room I was familiar with its
properties in fact uh even in my PhD
thesis I developed some automated tools
to let you draw escher-like tilings
based on Penrose tiles
um so modify the edges of Penrose tiles
to make them look more like whatever
shape you wanted uh way back in the day
Penrose himself had done such a
modification and produced the this
hilarious drawing of I think they kind
of look like chickens uh like two kinds
of birds and I I emulated that in my
work uh but yeah I mean
you know I'm I'm very interested in the
intersection of mathematics and art and
going into you know the 70s 80s 90s what
were the big emissaries of mathematical
Arts of the world it was basically the
mandrel broad set and Penrose tiles and
uh you know I I am extremely grateful
for the existence of Penrose tiles to uh
promote uh the popularity of mathematics
in general and tilings in particular to
the broader World they they have they
have done their job exceedingly well
never mind being a brilliant and
profound contribution to mathematics
so professor
obviously the Penrose tiling has this
property that but it requires two tiles
to do it and it was obvious the question
was could it be done with one tile what
was that kind of like the for Mars Last
Theorem of tiling was is that was that
the top thing was that the ultimate
tiling Holy Grail my mind yes that like
even 20 years ago back in those days
that was the thing that I became
fascinated by like it's such an a deep
and wonderful question it's kind of the
the fundamental question of tiling
Theory or the what used to be the
fundamental open question of Thailand
the one that if I could pick one to
solve it would be that one and you know
how lucky to be here today as I said
before
yeah I mean it's a wonderful question
there's only one way that I would say
it's different from from oslow's theorem
and this is something I've been
emphasizing a lot which is unlike
something like for mozilla's theorem I
wouldn't say we had a clear notion of
which way we wanted the answer to go
from us Last Theorem I mean it took a
long time to say that there were no
Solutions Beyond n equals 2 etc etc uh
but we we knew which way we thought the
answer would turn out just as like P
versus NP Ramon hypothesis they're open
but we have a pretty good idea of what
we think the answer ought to be the
existence of an aperiodic monotile this
is the kind of thing where the
mathematician says right you could like
you could try to prove it one way Monday
Wednesday Friday and try to disprove it
Tuesday Thursday Saturday and then take
Sundays off did you have a gut feeling
I was I was pretty much on the fence
um
I there's no obvious reason why such a
shape should not exist right there's no
clear evidence
saying why you shouldn't be able to find
one except for the historical fact that
nobody had after looking for a long time
the only thing that we can say for sure
that we could have said for sure up
until this year is that if no such tile
exists it would be very hard to prove
that fact at least that was my gut
feeling because that's a statement about
all possible shapes that none of them
are aperiodic monotones whereas if an
aperiodic monotone does exist at least
you have a thing whose properties you're
trying to prove so happily we live in
the good timeline where there is a shape
that we can talk about that has
tell me the discovery stormy tell me
your War Story how did it how did it
first cross your desk what's your from
your I know I know there are multiple
people involved Tell Me Through Your
Eyes
it's a wild ride it's completely
unlikely and should not be taken as a
model for how scientific discovery ever
happens it's completely ridiculous right
right it started last November
um David Smith who is not a
mathematician he's uh let's call him a
shape hobbyist as he likes to the term
he likes to use
um he emailed me out of the blue now you
know he wasn't a complete stranger we we
both knew who the other was we had
interacted a little bit via email over
the years and we knew each other from a
small mailing list online of people
interested in thailands uh but he
emailed me out of the blue in November
and uh was asking me about some of the
work I had done recently on uh using
software to measure computational tiling
properties of shapes was he did it was
he was he tipping his hand straight away
was he was he saying I think I've got
something or was he kind of feeling you
out first uh almost straight away his
first email was really just asking about
my research
um and he didn't specifically mention
that but I think that was the day that
he had initially found it and was
wondering what the deal was but a few
days later so you know his first if I
remember correctly he first emailed me
on November 17th and then on November
20th he emailed me again I I think I had
I responded and emailed me again and
said well here's the thing I'm stuck on
it's this funny poly kite shape and that
was the first drawing that I had seen in
the Hat so he wasn't playing too close
to the chest
what what did you think when you first
saw this shape in an email from David
the first time you laid eyes on the
shape did you did it did it resonate
with you or did you think oh here's
another here's another one that's not
going to work or yeah well so
I trusted David's Judgment at the outset
and and I say that because I had seen
some of the previous experiments that he
had done on his own that he had either
posted on his blog or shared on the
mailing list and uh he knew what he was
doing I mean that much was clear to me
even if I was not trying to like
evaluate it from a research perspective
I could tell that he had a keen uh
intuition for interesting shapes so I
was willing to Grant him some benefit of
the doubt but that being said my first
contact with the hat I mean it's a
really boring mundane shape there's
really nothing that you could point at
and say Ah that's why it's going to be
interesting it's just kind of a random
blob right so my first reaction upon
seeing it was like well we've got to
suspend judgment like David already said
uh it has a h number of at least three
which you know there's some technical
details there although you with Edmund
Harris made a wonderful video but about
page numbers so that would be a good
place to go look as a reminder of what
that of what that's about so when he
said it has a h number of at least three
he was already communicating to me like
there's something interesting going on
here and he couldn't make a tile
periodically that's the other half of
what makes it interesting so I I
couldn't see anything about the shape
immediately that that you know keyed off
my intuition but I was certainly willing
to dive deeper and try to you know plug
it into my software and see what came
out of that how long after
it was given to you to play with and
start doing some analysis on did you
realize this could be something special
uh I think it was only a couple of days
later I mean uh first of all David kept
experimenting and sending me well by by
the you know by three four days later he
was sending me photographs of cut out
paper hats that he had arranged on it on
a table and you know he could see you
could see the progress he was making
trying to trying to make the shape tile
of the plane and what was really
interesting about his photographs was he
had cut out uh he had a you know
computer-controlled craft cutter he had
cut out the reflected hats like the
opposite-handedness hats in a different
color paper than the unreflected has and
so immediately you could see it as
photographs the sparse distribution of
reflected hats among the unreflected
ones and that was a big clue that's like
wait a second like he wouldn't do that
unless he was somehow being forced to
create those kinds of Arrangements his
intuition would otherwise naturally have
guided him towards something simply so
the fact already that we were getting
this weird sparse arrangement of
reflected hats that was a tip-off to me
and then on the other on the other side
I had by then in fact adapted my
software to be able to automatically
compute large patches of hats by Brute
Force automatically so I could walk out
much farther computationally than David
was able to achieve by hand and just
that larger data set if we started to
color it in like say color in the
reflected hats in a different color
maybe color other things by orientation
it was looking really weird I mean like
again
this is a this is not a theorem this is
a statement I need tuition an intuitive
statement that my program would not
spontaneously create a composition of
tiles that's more complicated than it
strictly needs to be so the fact that
the computer was coming up with these
crazy non-repetitive arrangement of
tiles it's another big clue and that
sort of that set off the investigation
so as early as like a week after he
first emailed me David
uttered the phrase Einstein problem in
an email he said could this maybe be a
solution to the Einstein problem
wouldn't that be a thing and and I was
willing to agree with him at that point
like yeah we have to we have to figure
this out there's something going on here
I know it's like a mathematical
breakthrough but because it's so visual
it really conjures up images of me like
Howard Carter first glimpsing into
Tutankhamun's tomb and seeing a
beautiful thing and thinking oh my God
have have I found what I think I found
after all this dreaming
it is yeah well I mean that's that's the
the visceral excitement the Wonder I
mean that's the the moment I I always
think I don't know if this is too
obscure reference because we're talking
30 years at this point but I always
think of the movie contact
I don't know if you if you remember
contact the moment when Jody Foster
First turns the dishes in the vla and
hears the message for the first time and
her eyes like Snap open and she just
gapes right she can't believe what she's
hearing
I mean just to we should all be so lucky
as to have that feeling once in a
lifetime
yeah one moment can you put your finger
on a moment or was it too iterative or
was there a moment when you thought it
this is it this is we have we actually
have got it we found her
it was a little bit more gradual than
that but yeah I'd say even early on like
late November I was starting to feel
that feeling of like this I think this
is it I mean there was a lot more work
to do and we absolutely should get on to
the rest of the story because I don't
want to leave out my other collaborators
who were
who were absolutely crucial who did
things I could never have done
um but you know even in late November
there was that feeling that high of like
I think this is it like we're gonna have
we're not done we you know this is very
far from a proof of a mathematical
theorem but we're gonna get it
this is the shape well as we move on to
your collaborators and how the process
continues this is probably a good time
to ask
what did you do about like secrecy and
things like that like famously Andrew
Wiles when he cracked from our Last
Theorem was very secretive about it no
one even knew he was working on it until
he had announced the proof
were you trying to put a lid on it were
you saying to David hey keep quiet about
this I think I think we've got the big
one or were you like you know
broadcasting to everyone and it was all
hands to the pump
we we were not broadcasting the news far
and wide that's for sure yeah I think we
were trying to keep it a little bit to
ourselves and eventually the four of us
so I think even in the second part of
November like late November I was
telling David maybe we should
not spread this around too much at this
point interestingly
uh David had already emailed a couple of
people before me uh asking them for help
and it just so happened that they were
unavailable for different reasons so I
was a squeaker for me I got I got pulled
in at just the right moment and and
happened to have the right tools to help
with the analysis so those people are
like the people who turned down the
Harry Potter books yeah so look maybe
it's a little bit like that yeah yeah
but uh but yeah we we were trying to
keep it to ourselves a little bit so I
was telling people I think I'm on the
trail of a major Discovery and then you
know talking to colleagues like maybe I
would say well it's related to aperiodic
tilings but I wouldn't elaborate beyond
that and that was all the way up into
March when we finally announced the
paper and we met the other people and
who else you had to go to to stick the
landing right good so uh from through
the end of December I got David's
Indulgence to let me work on problem
with the feeling simply that once we
roped in other hardcore mathematicians
they probably solve it immediately and
then I wouldn't get to do anything else
so I it was really completely selfish
it's like please give me a chance to
keep playing I think I can make a little
bit more progress just between the two
of us and David was nice enough to
oblige and I promise like first thing
after New Year's day we'll we'll email a
few other people and get the ball
rolling so indeed yeah so early January
we reached out to Hein Goodman Strauss
who is you know a long time researcher
in tiling Theory and you know is well
known in that Community made some key
contributions to our understanding of
aperiodic tilings he he's one of the few
people other than Penrose who came up
with a two-shape aperiodic tiling or I
should say a an aperiodic tile set of
size two the trilobite and crab and you
can I mean it's easy to find online
which in some sense are two shapes that
with the appropriate matching conditions
recapitulate the structure of What's
called the chair tiling and so hayam got
in and you know didn't raise any
objections right from the get-go he's
like yeah this is looking really
interesting and then a week or two after
that uh we also reached out to Joseph
Myers now Joseph is also another
interesting person uh in terms of his
his past and his current work he's not
uh an academic he has a PHD in
combinatorics from Cambridge
uh so he's highly qualified and he has
an excellent background for exactly
these sorts of problems and he works as
a software developer so he's he's not an
active researcher he doesn't he doesn't
publish papers actively but I've known
of him for at least 20 25 years because
of this fantastic work he did
calculating or I should say Computing
the tiling theoretic properties of
polyaminos particularly or I should say
Paulie forms polyaminos poly hexes and
polyimens so he had systematically
searched through spaces of these simple
polyforms looking for how they tile the
plane or don't with inevitably the
agenda of trying to find an aperiodic
monotone so he could very well have been
the discoverer of the hat if only he had
looked in the poly kite box early on
instead of focusing all his Cycles on
polyhex's polygons polyomons but because
of this background he was perfectly
situated to help in the analysis of his
polycut like he had spent all of these
years preparing himself to prove the a
periodicity of a monotile if one should
come along and so when we presented when
we wrote them in and said here it is
well it took almost no time at all for
him to finish the proof
by the end of December I was able to
show that the Hat tiled the plane like
which is half of a proof of a
periodicity you need to show that there
are tidelines then you need to show that
all of those tilings are non-periodic
and I mean we we emailed Joseph on I
think it was January 17th and that was
his first exposure to this problem and
and this shape and on the 25th he
emailed back and said okay I think I've
got it like which
I mean it's both a testament to Joseph's
Amazing skill and maybe also a comment
on the fact that you know once you know
that the shape exists proving that it
has the properties you want it to have
maybe that's not such an Arcane process
when you finally went public and there
was this all this great publicity and it
was a it was it was a huge deal I
remember it was all it was certainly all
over my timelines but but initially
there was this issue that a certain
percentage of the tiles had to be
flipped reflected so you could argue it
wasn't one tile it was too it was some
people said well that's not one tile
that's two different tasks did that did
that irku was that like a stone in your
shoe that it wasn't quite as perfect as
it could be
I I wouldn't say that it's undermined my
feeling of having solved this open
problem like it it didn't
demolish the success of you know the
existence of an aperiodic
and and you know we could litigate this
all we want in some sense right this is
a this is a problem of definitions it's
not a flaw in a theorem where you can
say well this step I think you know
you've ignored this case this corner
case or something it's really a decision
about what the correct definition is of
a tiling by a single shape and it's
clear to our planet yeah I mean well
sure right like so
you I mean we could debate it all we
want but nobody's ever going to be right
or wrong because the question of what
the correct definition for something is
well that's a social process right it's
not it's not really a question of
mathematical correctness so but at the
same time the stone in my shoe was oh
yeah you're right that is also a really
interesting problem that we should work
on the question of whether there exists
a chiral aperiodic monoton so
um I wasn't so much disappointed as
excited about their still being a
non-trivial open problem that demanded
to be investigated well that one didn't
take long you guys came out with the
with the solution to that one sooner it
was crazy I mean and I you know I said
this is a problem that really ought to
be investigated I am not saying that we
then went off and started investigating
it no way I mean we were just as
everyone else was saying we were
thinking wow yeah that is a good problem
and who knows when we will understand
enough about a periodicity to find the
answer to that one see it's my it's even
harder and then as fate would have it
right we put the paper out I think it
was March 20th maybe I think it was 20th
or 21st right and then
um people started putting all sorts of
wonderful visual experiments online they
started playing around like you said the
response was incredible I mean just
wonderful to see and in particular
um yoshiaki araki who's a well-known
figure uh who plays around with tilings
and creates wonderful visual designs and
explores the visual properties of
tilings
um he had started posting some of the
pictures that he had created including
some based on what we call tile one one
the shape where all the edges have the
same length in the Continuum between the
hat and the turtle
and David just saw something there that
you know you know that that like you
know it it got playing around in the
back of his head something looked a
little bit strange there and he started
exploring well what happens if I try to
tile the plane using tile one one but I
don't let myself use Reflections and I
was like five days later so
it was a complete stroke of dumb luck
there none of the authors of that paper
you know none of the authors of the
first paper had any clue that we were
headed in the direction towards a chiral
aperiodic monotile I would never have
expected the answer to just shake out of
the work we had already done but there
it was which is not to say that uh the
answer was in the original paper too
just the shape right then we had to
reopen the whole Playbook and kind of
redo all the steps that we had done
previously just based on this new shape
proving it's a periodicity but I mean I
was astounded I I didn't I didn't
believe it at first I I think I I
literally said by email to David like if
this turns out to be a non-reflective
Einstein I'll eat my hat
well you know I guess I've had to do so
at this point
since it's all come out and there's been
some swirl of excitement what what's has
there been anything about it that has
surprised you or a crazy thing someone
who's called you or some article you've
seen or what like of all the things that
have happened since what's been your
favorite
oh uh
there's been I mean a lot of great
kind of fan art I guess that I've loved
seeing online
uh textile Arts are natural so people
have uh made quilts and crochet and
knitted hats all sorts of great I mean
there's obviously graphic art is a
natural choice and people have made
great esheresque interpretations of the
Hat the turtle the Specter and so on
um
Yoshi yoshiakiraki whom I just mentioned
uh he was experimenting as well with um
tiling a strip with Hats periodically
you can't fill the plane with Hats
periodically that's the whole point it's
an aperiodic monotonial but you can
actually tile a strip of any finite
width in a rep in a way that repeats
along that strip so he had printed out
like transparent tape with Hats like a
big roll of tape and he had applied it
around a beer glass
and then somehow we found like
tessellation beer like a brand of beer
called tessellation that's the whole
package I I really enjoyed seeing that I
think my favorite artistic
interpretation of the Hat was uh John
Paul wheatley's soccer ball the football
so a lot of people had noticed that you
can put six hats around a a space in the
shape of a regular hexagon and you could
tile the plane with those configurations
of six hats plus hexagon and John Paul
just realized well let's change that
hexagon into a pentagon and now you get
these pentagonal panels that can wrap
around to in a kind of dodecahedral
configuration and poof you have a
football and it's gorgeous I hope to see
it someday
I feel like the Hat came along and blew
everyone's mind and it became this
celebrity shape really quickly and the
Specter because of the nature of the
timeline of its Discovery even though
it's kind of even though I feel like
it's kind of a bigger deal it hasn't
taken on the mythical status of the Hat
do you do you have a favor of those two
shapes one that's a bit closer to your
heart
um I think I think probably the hat is
closer to my heart for kind of the same
reasons that you've already said I mean
the
the the plateau of discovery that the
Hat achieved is greater than the like
marginal extra step up to the Specter
they're they're all fascinating and
they're all gonna I think give us lots
of interesting ideas for the future the
Specter does some interesting things
that the Hat cannot in particular you
have you can modify its edges to do
anything you want and whereas with the
hat uh the edges have to be straight
lines you you actually have no degrees
of freedom if you want all the tiles to
have exactly the same shape so the
Specter in some sense is maybe going to
pay off more artistic dividends but yeah
the Hat will will probably always live
on as
relatively speaking a bigger Discovery
in my personal history
are you going to do anything crazy like
tile your bathroom with them or anything
I don't know I it's yeah I had uh maybe
a backsplash
I'm I'm much more hoping I'm holding out
hope we're uh we're gonna break ground
soon on my campus here at the University
of Waterloo on a new Math building and
so that would be the place where I can
put my hopes that we're gonna have
somewhere in that building where the the
Hat the Specter the turtle any number of
these can be on display gotta happen now
you've got to get in the rear if they
don't do that that's crazy
yeah yeah I've I've I I have the dean
has expressed excitement about that
possibility and that's about all I need
to hope for for now but yeah let's make
this happen yeah I can't imagine what it
must feel like to be a tile guy
and have the number one problem in your
field the Mount Everest of your thing
and you along with your collaborators be
the ones who crack up I can't imagine
what that feels like I just it must just
be the best feeling in the world or is
it is it deflating is it like now what
like it's like it's like something it's
like something special has been taken
from you in a way now yeah I I've told
people a few times like it's there's a
certain existential feeling that comes
from like
knowing in the moment that you're
probably doing the most important thing
you will ever do right like which
it's gonna I sure take this as a
challenge I will try to best myself
absolutely but let's be honest right
this could very well be the most
important thing I ever do so that is a
little bit of a melancholic feeling that
being said
um yeah the feeling is incredible as as
I I hope anybody who has already tuned
in to your podcast your your YouTube
channel and so on you know hopefully
part of the reason they do that is
because they can imagine the joy of
scientific discovery of mathematical
Discovery and I'm here to tell you that
yeah it is every bit as incredible as
you would hope it feels like and it yeah
it does and uh you know all I can do is
try to revisit that feeling uh when I
need it and ideally to try to recreate
it in the future with something else
there's a new tile in town so we've come
to the town of new tile to see what it's
all about
so you know your regular floor tiles how
they you know they go over and over they
cover the entire plane with a pattern
this new tile goes infinitely but with
no repeats
happy new tile